you
okay this is the RAM dick tournament
that's the name for this created
tournament three Oh time control
fifty-five minutes of blitz chess okay
this first game is not a top pairing
let's try knight c6
and II 5no increment uh-huh all right
see how we four is defended now I may
play d5 and open it up okay this feels a
little inconsistent like some time will
be lost this guy has to maybe move again
and maybe we launched an attack I'm
going to really give me the dark square
bishop how do you feel like I'm in a
good position
tonight f4 okay I'm on the bishop on a
bishop check I'm going to move my king
he is a really really strong piece I
cannot put a value on him Bishop h3 is a
move let's maintain my bishop let's just
go one step
I'm okay with going and castled feel
like I played this early start with like
it was bullet
it's a blend for sure you know a
three-minute somewhere in between bullet
and blitz Bishop h3 is a move because on
takes I have a matin couple let's still
do this and I could even consider h5 on
h3 or even a sacrifice you know
sacrifices seem to work let's get my H
pawn rolling maybe the Jeep on as well
now let's get the Jeep on involved drop
the bishop back you know all right I
have the G file to work with don't know
if that was the best way to capture how
I did it
hmm I want to stop Bishop here if I push
they would maybe try Bishop g4 this pawn
ever moves then there's maybe some way I
could get my rook here I don't like
having to play rook to b8 but I will on
99 to a5 let's push try to keep pressure
on them with the clock let's see I have
a pawn break let's get in h3 hmm give me
the h2 square keep pressure on f2 ready
to queenside castle now triple up on the
H file
that rook cannot move still going to
look to triple up I'm going to throw
some of their pawns at me
let's uh
hmm let's eat the bishop first maybe my
queen comes over here and tries to cause
some havoc this bishop is removed now
maybe this pawn is a serious hitting the
knight in the pond I'm okay with
grabbing some stuff over here now that
the position is opened up on this side
of the board Knight moves I have Queen
takes pawn wits check and let's just get
out of this stuff for starters and maybe
do what I could grab this pawn I've
banked a lot of time so maybe this is a
good moment to think a little bit
let's see you play rook here let's just
do that for starters see if the rip
plays over and then I'll play rook to c8
yeah at least the Queen doesn't in turn
put pressure on my seventh rank let that
little you know sequence of moves there
I feel like I gained just a little bit
he's probably a serious thorn and f3
let's defend them and put my bishop on a
better Square Queen takes e4
serious pin grab another pond thrown in
your fork clean trade I'm fine with but
their King is vulnerable let's keep the
Queen's on who I almost miss that may
threat I would have stung
excuse me that would have stung a little
bit I'd have to react to that let's get
up there night eleven seconds get sake
that Queen and then just go right here
and get back over scoop up that night or
get may in a couple ways back determine
okay that was a lengthy one
maybe there was a quicker finish but I
don't think the wind was ever in doubt
in that one once I had once they give up
their dark square bishop
my bishop on b6 has mentioned you really
tough to put a value on that guy it's
just really really strong he's uh what
we might say multi-purpose piece he's
super attacker and defender of my queen
side
okay let's try eform
a Sicilian
let's go straight in for an open Bishop
d3 Queenie to set up and I don't know
what I want to do with my knight just
yet yeah I do
Knight c3 is fine maybe push yeah let's
do it let's castle I'm okay with double
pawns here
and they're splitting their structure
save the h2 pond looking at 94 they have
a split structure I have double pawns
let's get on an open file for starters I
have Queenie form I'd like to have that
hit a couple different ways let's just
push in Queenie for this is also some
idea maybe the queen hitting at a 5 or a
4 multiple threats
let's stop this pawn from even moving
and maybe I could camp out on one of
these squares with my rooks especially
if the dark square Bishop Tsar exchanged
ok they've weakened their dark squares
hmm let's start with this they probably
want to occupy this file and now he's a
pretty big pest it's also observing this
hole that was just created so maybe we
look to now double on the V file
see if they weaken their King in order
to flush my bishop off this diagonal and
then his eyes light up some more as soon
as these pawns move the light squares
are weakened
let's go here strike at c6 and also this
is an idea let's try it
I could push now this is a really
invasive bishop really invasive this guy
moves I'm repositioning my light-square
bishop like a look for h4 h5 stuff right
around here doing all right on the clock
I'm okay with weakening my light squares
in order to try and get this advance in
continued good coordination all my
pieces are defended except for this pawn
I'm actually quite alright with a queen
trade I'd rather I'd rather keep them on
though yeah let's keep the Queen's on go
look at this stuff
yeah let's keep the Queen's own they
might try for this okay hmm
let's start with this move I think well
let's see yeah I want to get Bishop c4
in really soon yeah because this is
their plan
this is soon to be a strong piece Wow
well that's that shouldn't be working
though I got this covered
still and now I could just crash through
on c6 rook f4 if I need defensive f2
this might be happening
well Bishop interferes with that idea
let's get on the 7th right away now f3
first
rook here this is a really strong piece
dark square bishop in this game as well
I guess they could capture the pawn
their queen is defending this
I have a passport clean here I could
play rook takes f7 just do something
active the Queen releases pressure on my
bishop I could set him into motion I'm
threatening some bishop move right now
let's get pushing can maybe draw my
bishop back to defend against that pawn
let's keep pushing and how are they
defending this
just keep putting a rook on v8 now I get
to hit wits check and now we're winning
got it clean
and they resigned back determine okay
queen master is on a streak now you have
four games in 12 with fire I have four
with fire 43 minutes left okay let's see
who we get next ooh
queen master all right this is the pack
leader we got to chip away at the pack
leaders
all right d 4 and C 4 and E form
let's try H 3
Bishop g5 and Bishop III looking to
close shop on e5
yeah I'm going to go here just so I
don't have to budge once some more fuel
is added to e4 let's just build up in
the center some grab a nice tempo now
that h6 was in mmm I don't want the
Senate open up I could have considered
more just capturing there but I'm
alright what's playing this position
all right they're giving me this d5
square I think I should hop right to it
maybe not the best idea but hmm all
right how about that's a good move yeah
I like that move a lot hmm yeah I like
that move
very good yeah maybe I should have
calculated a little bit to win that H
phone because I didn't know I and I feel
like I'm really suffering d5 is a move
let's do this they could get this guy
but I have a couple passed pawns it's
dynamic position let's see how we do
they should be grabbing on e4 maybe it
isn't a upon that can be won so easily
suppose I take first and then play
Bishop b6
rook here I guess kind of once again
considered that even on time
I think it's mandatory this move is
played I'm just getting in this piece
for free now yeah they had to do this I
getting that piece back no I have Queen
a form and this oh my goodness I just
dropped my queen oh my god oh man
uhh
I just dropped my clean oh man
awful 1:32 I'll play on just a little
bit more ah man I drop my queen
and everything falls now ah man up a
piece and then down a queen let's just
try to be fancy with the night a little
bit scam
scare tactics hang on to your night
Oh ugliness
I got nothing I'll be resigning very
soon I think very soon ah man
well that wasn't the best he just gave
me that pond maybe they're nervous maybe
they're nervous that's what I have to
play for the nerves are they nervous
rook to d2 I got a night that's about it
let's just keep attacking that Queen for
a little bit yeah they could just
capture it here there's a good spot 40
seconds don't know if that's a good move
mm-hmm I guess we're going to go here
defend that crawling up into
tactic
thirty Seconds twenty-eight got avoid
these uh rook exchanges no 24 let's
attack the Queen 20 seconds okay hmm
I'm just looking for time burning
tactics that's all I am
let's try this
there we go got another pond 14 seconds
hmm
I'm in a pin and we have eight seconds
six they're going to try to get rid of
my last pawn
ah now I'm winning they got nervous ah
man
lucky dog who is a lucky dog it's me oh
man oh queen master you had me man you
had me on the ropes big time
ah man
shouldn't happen like that where was the
where was the finishing touch invested a
little bit more material probably okay
we're going to connect Knights we're
going to try not to drop a queen in this
game against the Queen Master I learned
our lesson against the Queen Master
don't drop your queen okay
I'm not doing this with the intention to
maintain the pawn but I don't want to
give up give up this Square to the white
pieces now I could maintain this pawn
because I'm in there in time to have my
rook defended boom-boom so I have IVA I
want some space on the Queen side
let's counsel flight square rook e8
let's hang on to him I would have rather
doubt you know have that kind of stuff
happen but let's develop Queen d7 Knight
f5 maybe a four a six let's get this
move in Knight f5 soon
oh let's jump in now they're going to
help improve my light square bishop now
let's keep dark square bishop surround
you know this is my better bishop that
said I think I need to watch out for
this stuff
Bishop move and then dropping in here
let's get on this file there's a big
fight going on for the e5 square
I think they've given up on a four could
take that Bishop out I have control over
this square my knight my knight defends
that and my bishop can help out soon
all right that's a nice move and it's a
move that actually traps my knight so
once again I'm going to have to work
some magic
ah
magic again I have a time edge I didn't
realize my night was short on squares
unfortunately let's start with this and
let the time burnin tries begin
God defend that pond keep Queens on for
sure
okay I don't know let's just throw a
quick punch at the rook and keep that
square covered yeah I may need to get
rid of Queen soon this night I know five
is really strong okay
I guess here I want g6 in really soon
right there can they really rely upon
that night hmm he's a bit out of play it
must be said
oh that works though yeah that works hmm
they're going to get this guy that's not
cool
okay I'm officially down a full rook 55
seconds
ah that's not fun but yeah okay they
didn't want that rook all right I guess
I'm going to save them now and then
improve my King a little bit
I think my king can rely no he can't
rely upon that square I have to defend
with Bishop c6 they have 36 seconds
their knight doesn't have many squares
maybe I could hold things up with this
Bishop and Knight combination their
Knights kind of stock my rook is it
active let's give this check oh they
might run into mate if they do that
scooped up a pawn I have a passed pawn
now let's get him working let's give
this check oh they take they can't stop
my pawn this might be working hmm I
insist
now it's winning think wow it's like two
rabbits out of a hat
oh man
time mm-hmm ugliness I'll take the
double use I don't want to win like that
but uh yeah no dropping my queen
dropping a piece I didn't see that my
knight was short on squares g4 nice move
okay 30 minutes 22 seconds left where do
we have top guy has 16 I have 12
how about we try you four why not ah
okay let's kick that night around okay
let's just go with Knight f3 take what
the night I have to worry about a pin
now I guess Bishop d3 I'm doing this to
stop Bishop f5 I have these squares
covered
I guess they're going to go King side or
King side fiend keto let's go c3 Bishop
g5 this could be a bit annoying
converging on e7
wouldn't mind seeing this stuff happen
let's get my knight involved knight on
f3 Knight f4 we'll just drop my Bishop
back hmm
they really weakened their King just
then let's get out of this pin ASAP
hmm um suppose I pin what are they doing
now okay
I'm playing against an isolated pawn now
hmm
let's uh chase that night away from its
central post does it even have to go in
Reverse opposite color bishops to add
more fuel to this night get him to budge
he budged this Knights out of play now
still this pin going on against the pawn
my queen is soon to get really active if
they challenge my rook Queen swap and
then Queen f7 h4 h5 comes to mind maybe
we have this in in mind right now if the
knight gets too fancy maybe this ski
pressure on the clock um do I want to
allow each three now let's try to win
this pawn maybe he's gone too far yeah
I'm going to try to show that he's
overextended somehow by adding more
pressure to him Knight f6 Queen here and
then I could look to remove the knight
and then win here should probably try
III but they have to have to calculate
that to see that they could get out of
the pin and they have the more
vulnerable King Bishop here next I
straight away okay let's play this
opposite color Bishop ending
Bishop f3 and time let's make sure this
stays as is I don't want to see a three
it's going to be a slow one
g3 kin G to get my King on a light
square h4 h5 is an idea but first things
first
okay let's get this in before they go
here this I want to keep this structure
for my King this is going to be an ice
hut for my king
okay he's on the light square that's
nice next phase is what exactly
let's go here this is tricky
I've pressure against this pawn
okay let's try something different here
I don't want to have to do this but
maybe I maybe I have to okay they're not
they're not putting me back in the pin
hmm what concerns me is rook here if I
move my Bishop rook takes and then Queen
takes here suppose I play g4 though try
and show that their Queens offsides
let's try this get a g6 along a file
very committal move but I think that
this is the correct way forward okay so
probably just take and now I know what
let's go here Bishop takes I have a
discovery it's ready to drop my queen
man
being a little sneaky right now Bishop
takes pawn queen here
so all I have sneaky moves all right
let's enter a little bit got this square
covered if you like I have two threes
the move yeah let's do it
and hmm
I don't have much time
grab this pawn here
it's a rare race
they're not going after this guy why not
check
in a trade rook's why'd I do that
ah man get the rooks off they're down on
time my goodness
ah these games tough 23 minutes and
change where we stand here 20 1916
okay see what we get
how about
see five against Odie
d 5 and let's just look to recapture on
C 5 are there going to be greedy trying
the hang on now this is very weakening
and the night is upset
that's his favorite square clean B 6
threads to win material this is still I
think good III is sensitive and I might
look to add more pressure to it okay
they're kicking me off of that diagonal
but have weakened the Queen side
immensely for holes so a rook will like
the C file that much more now let's make
sure it stays open I don't want to see
e5 I could have maybe just played Knight
here first yeah because I just helped
out there Knight by capturing I should
have played here straight away but okay
let's not go there straight away let's
focus on this squared what's he do
Queens in the way it's Castle shouldn't
have allowed that should be alright but
I'm definitely not playing this the best
they're giving me upon okay where to go
my light square bishop
let's just get a counter-attacking move
in I will take that definitely Bishop g2
rook here I'm on that long diagonal get
my King on e7 that's where he belongs
towards the center now I'm up a bond I'm
ok with some trades the King and pawn
ending is winning if they play rook to D
- let's save my jeep on I could have
just gone there what was I just saying
King and pawn ending his winning
let's give a check first now what
to go back let's win this pond okay I'm
on c4 now dropping pawns I have two
connected passed pawns now I'm going to
get these guys rolling on v6 I guess I
could just capture or push let's improve
the King a little bit
rook exchange watch out for any
sneakiness and we're good to go
let's kept pushing they resigned back to
tournament 24s in first twenty Ferrari
IC is now in there and here he is three
Oh time control against Ferrari
let's try Knight f3
and d3
look Oh a kingside FINCAD oh by Ferrari
let's go rookie 1 for starters maybe d4
soon let's kick that bishop away first
let's get enough for actually
why not my rook it feels like it should
be back on f1 now that I have a foreign
King h1 let's just secure my night for a
moment King h1 Bishop e3
and then Bishop g1 a knight Knight g4 I
don't want to do this feels to weaken to
weaken g3
let's do it
pack up they give up this square now 95
should be pretty strong it's the only
way I can recapture
it's a bit annoying
hmm
okay let's do this first and I'm going
to look to shut down this diagonal with
D for right now and maybe even a five
just try to put a clamp down immediately
on this guy which is maybe too soon
because I do give up this square put
immediate pressure on it on a night move
I have this maybe they have to do this
first Knight d5 is looking pretty strong
takes pawn takes push Bishop efore this
kind of stuff
offsetting my strong bishop he's really
important to me what's also important is
that I keep my queen on the board to
defend c2 for the moment they gave me
the F file with that capture they may
look to undermine my center more really
sharp position right now 130 that's a
pretty slow move how do I even dislodge
this Knight I think it's it's the
correct thing to kick this night away
from the action he's too strong
I don't think they can make use of make
use of g3 so easily
and I want to get rid of this bishop
it's really strong how about Queen e2 in
the 94 maybe Knight g3 Queen d7 king h2
let's go here
right there I cover f4 with my bishop
notice what my knight moving now I'm
free to kick this night away these are
the two pieces that were bothering me so
trying to get rid of them
Knight h4 is now a possibility but I
don't want to take my knight away from
guarding this Center
let's secure my Center kick the night a
little bit
giving up that square okay they can drop
in there and get my light square bishop
if they want I'm a pretty good time edge
I got to take with my queen to defend
this I think I have really good play
this Knight d6 move should be a killer
he's just hitting everything yeah so
they got rid of them now their night is
looking to bring the pain let's double
up like g5 let's first offset the night
and I guess we do this alright we're
going to have a queen trade
advantage
hmm can I get these pawns rolling let's
open up this file for my rooks my knight
Bishop here hitting the rook
I want my bishop to defend my B to pawn
a little bit scary right here
hmm
I can't really find a good spot for my
king
who
this is happening soon it feels let's
try this move make some think at least
my night is going to be kicked very very
soon I think I could deal with that
though here
now let's keep pressure on this pawn
let's give a check okay I have this and
I could rely upon this position I
believe now let's just take the bishop
and then like to take this pawn I could
do this because I have a check
and next up let's win this pond
you know the time pressure is a bit much
now
let's get some trades in the end I have
two ponds
get the rooks off and then fly
and then fly
down on time a rat race at the end 13
minutes and change 32 25 24
when will I get one of these two top
dogs if at all may happen that we don't
get paired up 13 and change couple speed
bumps there we go
spinal tap got them let's try 9 2 6
nimzo-indian why not
classical Queen c2 huh let's try this
capture and then II five right away see
where why he puts his pieces
see five knight c6 expecting this kind
of stuff
d5 97
let's go here they're going to play off
three and I'm prepared to just drop back
to d7
I don't want to Castle kingside too too
soon
you know let's just secure c5 you don't
want to drop c5
okay night here now although now if I go
there there's this stuff so kingside it
is
a locked Center I may try for h6g five
before Knight g6 let's shoot for that
that move huh well let's take with the
night and think I could Castle we're
going to look for efore ideas we're
going to play on the Kings side looking
for e4
although I have to be really careful
because of d6 wouldn't mind seeing the a
file open up yeah maybe this was a bad
idea I should be trying for something
else like maybe this I'm okay with
double deaf pawns if this happens
because my King I'll find a nice home
here if they invest the dark square
bishop
let's try for this keep them guessing
about an e for idea
their king is more vulnerable they've
moved their Jeep on twice I think I want
to keep the Queen onboard so calm
they're locking down on that idea I see
I could take him whenever though looking
for a b5 break let's see
uhh
I could do this
yeah take with the Queen unrep takes
rook I want to get in b5 okay right now
is the time to do that hmm let's just
get a quick move in kind of semi passing
another semi passing if they go h4 I
think I'm going to go through now that
move isn't working hmm have to come up
with a plan here let's try the doubling
I could have gone for that sooner wasted
some time they're clearly making some
passing moves but I could have looked
for this doubling idea much sooner my
fear was playing b5 is that I end up in
some pin that I can't easily get out of
or even on the clock you're pushing
straight away I don't want the H valve
open up
let's go here on king g4 I have g6 I
think looks like a weird move I think
it's good
defends the night and there is no pawn
takes here sharp position very strategic
their King is um walking a tightrope
with the Queen salon I mean I could
still shift over here like maybe right
now actually how about I take and play
queen c8 how they defending here the
Queen has to go back it's not easy to
get out of that pin though I can look
for b5 or just a capture first you know
something something where the rook comes
to this this side okay now I could take
like this and then push I think I'm
winning material now with the push and
then an ensuing double or not double
check about to discover check and they
see that now Bishop d3 go here break the
pin and then pawn takes I have this
discover check there's something more I
don't think so
alright let's just trade Queens I insist
what's that move about oh they Mouse
slip there the down on time a little bit
but they wanted to play rock a7 I had a
piece I don't know if I should have
traded Queens there because I was
defending a my g7 square with my knight
so I wasn't a threat 36 30 30 and forth
with fire one more game and that's
probably yet let's try to make it a good
one a mouse leap or maybe a sneak artist
move maybe Adi all right let's try c5
okay I could get this one maybe I could
sneak into the podium
is that a mouse slipper did they
genuinely want to move the bishop to h3
okay
try and pile up on that night
is already a serious move Knight to d4
six-minute mark I'll just drop back
still observe this up on whose are now
very weakened because of c4
he's bound to fall the sky and d3
uhh
now let's let's let's target d3 right
away
could challenge that night way to peace
feel like there's no rush what's taking
here he's attacked three he's only
defended one he's going nowhere most
likely all right I'll go there now less
than to its castle
that could have also captured on c4 okay
and let's post up in the center they
have a weakened King let's so let's keep
the Queens on take with the pond pass
pawn maybe even open up the F file the
king is opposite my rook some stuff in
the way but it can be cleared out the
knight can certainly move F pawn could
get involved we might just have that yes
right here don't know if taking with the
rook is best now we're going to take
with the Queen hitting at H 3 and F 2
let's get one more move in with tempo
maybe even another grabbing a lot of
space with tempo
and
even win the Rucker do we take now the
Queen will recapture let's do this on
pawn takes I get to take or discover
check now and this slams the door on the
Queen side really is structure so now
it's getting blasted open the F file
where's the mate that's with check
should be right around the corner that's
not it let's try this first threatening
mate in one
you
all right they missed it back to
tournament three minutes 13 seconds
I have a tie-break I guess
they have me in second okay this is the
top guy I'm not going to finish so let's
just try and make this one a good game
okay Knight f3
mirela PES
with d3
okay I'm going to go for something like
this instead of any c3 d4 idea I like
going for this piece play type stuff
could take their dark square bishop
let's go for that
and I want to immediately challenge that
night I'm looking at the b4 move at some
stage
maybe h3 was better first I need to get
out of this pin really soon I'm gonna
put my queen on III who Bishop versus
Knight let's lock down on this pond and
maybe target him they're going for a
quick f5
yeah I'm going to do change of plans
they're going to go f5 okay I'm fine
with that
now I'm going to look for f4 they've
obstructed the ref pawn so let me get an
F for right now a bishop on this
diagonal should be pretty beasts like
Queen here now
okay well how about my bishop on this
diagonal right now g5 would be illegal
hmm let's do this
looking to target g7
my bishop is better than their knight in
this position pretty sure
who
my queen is unprotected let's go here I
want them to capture me I don't want to
trade too much
and see that move
Queen III even in ending a bishop versus
night ending with the without the Queen
should be good actually pawn takes I win
the Queen
yeah they're not not having any of that
hmm okay
I just come over here
let's try that
I've used a lot of time let's come back
over okay we're going to have some
trades much more simplified hmm let's go
here they take my rook I get to
recapture wits check I don't know how
good of an idea that says I am on their
night as well I didn't want it okay
Bishop takes Knight right now is this a
one King and pawn ending let's try for
this what's me being down on time I'm
going to try for something a little bit
simple
maybe I win the a pawn straight out one
King and pawn ending mmm let's go here
first and then I'm going to keep the
rooks on I can't work out if it's a one
King and pawn ending
let's give this check look back and you
know we're just repeating too much let's
go here I want to play for something I
feel like I need to get my King working
maybe repetition was best yeah hmm maybe
now we try to get the rook over to the a
file
I don't know to try for a draw here with
the time situation would even be a draw
though
look a like a draw
I was ready resigned this is a pretty
locked position
I'm going to play it on a little bit
this is a dead drop a little repetition
no pulling on time
there we go repetition okay yeah I felt
like I should have had something there
with the bishop but just it got too
simplified
yeah it was silly I mean the trickier or
the idea I think that black had at this
point was to meet rook here with a pawn
push and he's just a really good piece
more can I say he defends the pawn he
cuts off my king from where he wants to
be so I need to do something different
right around here I wanted to see this
tension resolve much sooner and somehow
get a rook here but it just couldn't
make it happen okay that wraps up the
Kramnik tournament just out of podium
land Ferrari got another game in there
so beat me out to the podium final
standings forty thirty seven thirty four
thirty two fifty five players and all
let's have a look at page two three four
five and six
alright that's going to do it to the 54
view that took part of this good games
all
you